I was gonna dive into the hole you know
that whole thing that you know we went
through with the re thing but people
have heard of it too many times we don't
really heard Natasha's ideas what do you
say they say anything bad about me no
just that you broke his heart but do you
remember that one that one has met one
thing that when he you know what wait so
what happened he punched you in the face
or he threatened to punch you in the
face
I don't remember your [ __ ] know I
think he's choked it with a telephone
card oh yeah yeah the first time right
he hit me from behind
and they kicked my face like 18 times I
don't mean to laugh he kicked your face
yeah where I was bleeding from my face
I'm sorry oh I don't know if I forgive
you yet I make eye contact with me for
three years I know or maybe more five
years I know that was weird there was a
period where you guys weren't friends it
wasn't that it was look at me I just
wouldn't look at her he'd be like hey
because you were resentful that you got
kicked in the face you know I just um it
was just a weird [ __ ] thing man it's
all it's all care how's that her fault
that you got kicked in the face it's not
her fault
and I never really blamed her for
anything that was a little weird when
you were I would I could see you not
talking to Ari but not talking to me
that's kind of rude that is rude but can
I tell you why though okay if you want I
will I'm gonna is after the first
beating I asked you for I asked you can
you call him and tell him that I had
nothing to do with you and Ron hell are
ya and you're like I'm not gonna call
Ari but he I was but I was getting beat
up by him so I was mad about that he was
like beating you up like like a burrito
like you know like you like there he was
a bit like a bully yeah heat up a kid
out all the time yes I did not know that
yeah and then a week later he strangled
me to the point where I would turn
purple and my neck was bleeding and you
guys are friends now yeah and then when
we did that Comedy Central that was the
thing that I yeah periodically like
splash water in your face no that was
her Comedy Store and all of a sudden I
just heard someone say you don't belong
here and throw a drink in my face
yeah and then I remember I was with
Morgan Murphy and she came out of the
bathroom and she yeah anyway you know
who confronted him rent
Morgan didn't know you know else dead
you dove Davidoff Oh Bryan Callen well
that was nice they both got up right and
followed him into the [ __ ] the steps
that go in the alarm and screamed at him
well I got scared that he would like
throw acid on my face or some eye god
cuz he just I mean that's a little crazy
to start strangling your friend
he threw water your face he strangled me
punched beat me up he was going through
a [ __ ] time that guy he had your
words on his wall you were probably a
real Idol to him yeah I think P or R and
it hurt him whatever he thought that I
did hurt him to the point where it
became Shakespearean you did you did do
it though it was it was because of you
that we were together you still talk to
Ron yeah sometimes he sometimes tweets
at me and stuff like that yeah yes he's
the one though especially that I just
was the one that I turned my back on oh
I see and I was with him so that made
sense
it's not that it's just that when he saw
you in the belly room that night before
you even came up to you he said to me he
goes who's that girl I thought was my
friend Natasha and he goes that she's
the one she's not the one because she's
with my fan or a I don't care you guys I
don't care and then you gave him my
number no I know you didn't
[Laughter]
[Music]